[Music]
tim is in charlotte north carolina hi
tim how are you
doing all right how are you doing better
than i deserve how can we help sir
ma'am all right um
so basically uh kind of my little
situation here i'm 19 uh currently uh
cash flowing my way through school
um the only debt that i currently have
is
in a uh car payment for uh 17 grand and
i love everything about the car don't
get me wrong but
um
i love everything about it except for
the price and
i really wanna um
like basically me and my mom are
co-signed under the same loan
i really want to trade it in and um
basically get like a
used car
um something that i can that i can do
for
work and school
um
but i just i it's it's so
the way my parents are they don't want
me to trade in the car they'd rather
have me have a new car and pay off the
debt like they want me to pay off the
bet
but i mean i really want to sell it so
basically my question is how do i get
them on the same page
uh so i guess i could
get it get it going out of my life
wow
um whose name is on the car
uh it's um both my mom and um
on the title or on the left side
on the loan whose name's on the title
uh it is
my mom's name under the title
so your mom owns the car
yeah yeah practically yep yep no she
does
legally she owns the car
the car's title to her
okay and uh you owe nineteen thousand on
it
i own uh seventeen thousand seven
thousand what's it worth
um
i kelly blue
uh well i went to kelly blue book last
night and
um they said it was at 25
through dealership so
private i could probably get
like 27 28 for it
and that would give you the cash to buy
a car assuming your mom let you have the
cash from the sale of her car
basically yes
do you live at home and i mean
yeah i live at home um
yeah and this is something that i use
you know every day for commute
um like i mean i drive
um like 30 minutes each way you know to
work and back and then you know school
is another
um 15 minutes out of my way and yeah i i
i don't
i mean i i put quite a bit of miles on
my car how many it's right
how many um uh my mom's starting what do
you make a year or what are you making
what kind of my income are you making
um right now i'm uh i guess i princess
welder so i don't make uh too much i
only make 15 an hour right now
uh so whatever that adds up to
and what are you going to school for
i'll go to school for welding
okay when will you graduate
uh be graduating summer of next year
with my certificate do you have any
money saved
that's in your account uh
yeah i mean i i have a um a thousand
dollars like basically a thousand
dollars saved up because i've been i've
been uh
kind of chunking away at the debt who's
paying for sometimes
i'm paying for school currently
it's very interesting
well
the first place we start is with
persuasion
and with respect
mom and dad thank you you've been a huge
blessing to me
what i need you guys to understand is
that this car is stressing me out
it is not a blessing
i know you want me to have a nice car
and i understand that i cannot stand
this debt anymore
i'm getting anxiety from this debt i'm
freaking out because of this debt i've
got to get this debt off of me
you've got to sell this car mom
yeah and i would just add to that i
think that's great i would just add a
little bit of vision to the persuasion
i'd show her all the different kind of
quality cars you can get right now for
ten thousand dollars assuming you sell
it for 27 yo 17. show her some other
nice dependable cars now we can get a
nice car for ten thousand dollars i
won't have any payments
and then when i finish school i'll be
able to walk out of here and get my
welding job and get out on my own with
no car payments and this is scaring me
to death i i cannot sleep i've got
anxiety this is driving me nuts mom and
dad i need you to let me
loose set your people free
yes yeah yeah and like my plan my plan
originally was to me graduate debt-free
my like my goal is to
um you know have 50 000 cash by the time
i'm twenty four so that's why you know
when i move out i have a good down
payment you know you're not gonna you're
gonna move out long before then you're
gonna move out long before then yeah
because you're gonna you're gonna have
your full-time job after you graduate
and you don't need to live at home
anymore i mean you'll be fine
you you know you'll be making a lot of
money as a welder won't be an apprentice
anymore and you won't have any car
payments because you're going to talk
them into this
um the second thing you can do but it
starts to get nasty is um
mom i'm not paying the payments anymore
on your car
the car's in your name it's your problem
i'm not going to pay the payments
anymore
yeah i ask you nicely to sell it i told
you it's stressing me out and it's the
net the car is in your name so you can
do whatever you want to do with your car
mom
um at which point you're going to figure
out how to get a car
and you may have to figure out a place
to live because they may put you out
um because you know you're under their
roof
so um but that you know or you may have
to just wait till summer to get rid of
the car
uh when you move out that would be the
time to get rid of the car and then you
can play that hand mom i asked you to
get rid of it now i'm just telling you
here's the keys to your car
and good luck with that car send your
name
and um and she'll sell the car and
she'll be
angry at her ungrateful son
but um that that's after you said please
please please sell it i'm stressed out i
can't stand this debt and she couldn't
hear you because
um
she's a bit controlling at that point
um and so i don't know i hope it doesn't
go that direction there's a whole i
don't think it will dave i think that
was great advice and i i i think it's uh
i think it's both and i like your first
tack
and and i like the second one it's he
presents them both at the same time
so mom we either sell this because of
all the things you described and you
also can say look here's what i can buy
it's very dependable car and i'm going
to take the money i've been paying
towards the loan and here's how much
money i'm going to be able to save up
cast a vision um because i think she's
controlling because of some type of fear
she has yeah and i think when he shows
that second scenario or mom then
technically it is yours and i'm going to
start taking the money i've been paying
towards a loan i'm going to save up for
a car for a beater and eventually get a
10 000 or whatever i think he i think he
forces that to let her have to deal with
what my baby doesn't want the car on
people i think it's going to work in his
favor yeah
yeah and that's what you know
but
that that's the thing that's the thing
so it's weird what's going on with a
parent who'll go no i'd rather pay debt
payments on a car because they think
that they're always going to have debt
and they're teaching them a lesson on
how to handle debt it's just stupid
ben is with us ben
it's true though ben's going to be up in
another hour not this hour so um but
anyway yeah i cause he wants to pay it
off he wants to sell it and they're
going no
here's the thing so you think that's
conditioning yeah it's mom and dad
believe it yeah they don't believe
they're bringing harm to him right of
course no no no yeah and they
they think he's just being silly and
naive well you're always gonna have a
payment son so you might as well just
understand that now wow and um you know
because a lot of people believe that
yeah and that leaves him in this
situation so the main thing to him is
don't be disrespectful
uh don't be angry
uh don't be unkind
uh and don't be ungrateful
i'm very grateful for what you've done
here but i just can't do this anymore
it's breaking the back of my spirit it's
killing me
and i just can't do it anymore set your
people free please
and i i think if you go that way that
you can at least get hurt and add to
that what ken was saying and that is
uh here's a vision of where we're going
i mean you can take the money from the
car the equity in this car it's unusual
time in the car markets buy a ten
thousand dollar car that'll do
everything this car does
um you're 19 years old in a 25 000 car
making 15 an hour at his age i was
driving a car that had 300 000 miles 15
an hour
[Music]
how did you think this was a blessing